♪ Went out one night to
make a little round ♪
♪ I met little Sadie,
and I shot her down ♪
♪ Went back home,
jumped into bed ♪
♪ .44 pistol under my head ♪
♪ I woke up in the morning about
half past nine... ♪
♪ ...they overtook me in
Jericho ♪
JESSE: Je déteste ces trucs.
ELLIE: Ouais, moi aussi.
JESSE: Ton vieux
m'est tombé dessus aujourd'hui.
ELLIE: Qu'est-ce qui s'est passé?
JESSE: Il m'a encore fait la morale
sur mes rondes.
"Ne fais pas ci, ne fais pas ça"…
C'est drôle,
il s'implique vraiment
quand t'es de patrouille.
ELLIE: Ouais.
JESSE: Elle est vraiment
à fond.
ELLIE: Je vous donne deux semaines
pour vous remettre ensemble.
JESSE: Laisse tomber.
Elle t'a dit quelque chose?
ELLIE: Une semaine, en fait.
DINA: Ellie. Salut.
T'en a mis du temps.
ELLIE: Au moins, je suis venue.
JESSE: Dina.
DINA: Jesse.
Viens.
JESSE: N'oublie pas,
on part à l'aube.
Alors essaie de te reposer.
DINA: Oui, chef.
ELLIE: T'abuses.
DINA: Allez.
Ne commence pas, toi aussi.
Bon, j'ai une question
très sérieuse pour toi.
Je sens mauvais?
ELLIE: Autant qu'un gros tas d'ordures
fumant.
DINA: Ah, parfait.
Et maintenant?
ELLIE: T'es dégueu.
DINA: Arrête, t'adores ça.
ELLIE: Tous les mecs
ont les yeux rivés sur toi.
DINA: C'est peut-être toi
qu'ils regardent.
ELLIE: Mais non.
DINA: Ils sont peut-être
jaloux de toi.
ELLIE: Je suis juste une fille,
pas une menace.
DINA: Ellie...
Je pense
qu'ils devraient être terrifiés.
[Gémissements]
ELLIE: Connard.
Merde.
[Sifflements]
[Corbeau croassant]
[Voix lointaine]
Ne faites pas ça, pitié.
Non.
Écoute.
Putain.
Non!
Non, non, non.
ELLIE: Bordel.
[Sifflements]
HOMME: On se déploie.
FEMME: Un Loup! Un Loup!
[BANG]
ELLIE: Merde.
FEMME: Elle s'est planquée
dans l'herbe.
Fais gaffe.
[Sifflements]
FEMME: Ethan.
ETHAN: Quoi?
FEMME: Un Loup,
elle est passée par ici.
Merde.
Fais demi-tour.
Allez.
[BANG]
ETHAN: Sale rat.
ELLIE: Salopard.
[BANG, BANG, BANG]
HOMME: Ethan!
Je la vois.
[BOOM]
FEMME: Ici!
HOMME: On est dans un monde
de sacrifices.
Argh.
[Musique]
DINA: Tu vois,
je te l'avais dit.
Ils devraient être terrifiés.